こんにちは
Dr.ハジメだ
おさかなさん
というわけで子供たちの皆
久しぶり
夏休みの自由研究どのような物をやってますでしょうか
自由研究と言っても様々な物があります僕は確か小学生の時に何をしたかと言うと
カップラーメンの容器でUFОを作りました
まあ自由研究はこう色々あると思うんですけどもーまあやはり
王道な自由研究といえばーそうスライム
まあ私Dr.ハジメ何を言おうともーこのYouTube界にスライムを持ち込んだ伝説の男
スライムは本当に簡単に作れます
洗濯糊とホウ砂この二つがあれば基本的にはスライムが作れます
ただ今日やるのは
普通にスライムを作るのでは物足りません
Dr.ハジメの自由研究
僕は夏休みにこんなスライムを作ってみようと思います
待って
待って…
ヴォエェッ
待って、何で開いてるの
え～待ってマジで嫌なんだけど～
うぉ～オイオイオイ
ヴヴヴ
はい、という
ウッ、おわっ、クッ…
はい、というわけでDr.ハジメの自由研究
…作ってみようと思います
幸い今回上の方に、いい感じの被検体がいるので
ゲロの出るスライムを作って
彼らに嗅がせてみようと思います
果たしてゲロの出る液体とスライム
合体すると
ゲロの出るスライムが作れるかどうか
実験してみようと思います
では行こう!
はい、というわけで早速作って行きましょう
用意するもの
うっ、ヴヴヴ
ちょっと開けてみましょう
こぼれた分がこん中にあるんで
こん中の液体をなるべく
バケツに入れたい
なんか臭いの種類が変化してますね
ヴエェッ
ヴォエェッ
ヴヴォエェェッ
すいません、お見苦しいシーンだと思うんですが
許してください
はぁ…はぁ…
では早速スライムを作って行きましょう
まずはコップに、
ゲロの出る液体と、洗濯糊を
同じ量入れます
ウウウ…ウウッ
じゃあ入れます
キモイよ～…
くくくく…
いや、でも決して汚物ではないので
ご安心ください
あの日常の生活の中で
進化し続けて生まれてしまった液体でございます
化学物質です、決して汚物ではございません
ご了承くださいませ。
で、これと同じ量洗濯糊を入れていきます
うっわ臓器痛っ!
入れます
で、混ぜていきます
あれ割といけてる？
おっ…
あー盛大にこぼした終わった人生
でこっちにホウ砂を入れます
だいたい5g程度入れましょう
オッケー
でホウ砂入れた後混ぜます
オッケーです
ウエエエ
で、この2つを混ぜたら完成です
混ぜなきゃ…
なんか思ったよりそれっぽい物が出来ました
え、ちゃんと出来てんじゃないこれ
オエッ　あ、あごがぁ(？)
助けて
ヴヴヴヴエェッ!!
はいというわけで完成しましたこちら!
ゲロの出る液体で作ったスライム
ゲロの出るスライムです!
まぁちょっと上手くできたかどうか分かんないんですけど～
明らかにおかしな固形みたいな物が出来ました
なのでこれがきっとスライムなんだと思います
弾力性はそんな無いにしろ、
ちゃんと固形になってるんで
後ちゃんと伸びますね。一応スライムでございます
臭いのほう嗅いでみようと思います
ウウウッ…ゴホッ　オエッ
ちゃんと出ます
はい、というわけで無事ゲロの出るスライム完成したので
早速上の被検体に
本当にこれが効くかどうか
実験してみましょう。では。
検証開始です
アイッス
一回皆に嗅いでもらいましょう
カワグチジン：ウッフッ
カ：いや、もういいって
（笑）
相馬トランジスタ：アウウウッアエエエッ
相：吐き気
エイリアン過ぎる…
（笑）
へきほー：ウウウウウウ！
へ：ウエッ！ウエッ！
へ：何これ何これ！何これ！
嗅いで嗅いで
へ：ウッウエェェッ！
昔使ったゲロの出る液体の
スライムバージョンです
へ：いやもう最悪やこれ
これにて、これにてもうゲロの出る液体は収縮したんでもう
相：あ、終わったんだもう
これで終わりました
最終章でございました
(拍手)
カ：だいぶ俺らゲロの…
へ：ヴォエェッッ!!ヴォエェッ!